beside this is yellow wolf catfish bill
in your checking out bootleg care.com
and right after you get through cruising
come over and highlight me on Twitter
that's at yellow wolf at ye la wo 11 the
best of luck suckers to kiss my pickle
adjust a lip up and [__] Parker
specifically southern Louisville Slugger
talked on the Chevy bubble to burst your
bubble oh man bootleg caviar in Ojai 975
one of my favorite mcs right now
Yelawolf just got to tearing it down man
on stage I've never seen you live and I
I must say it's very rare to see Cassidy
music is dope was in performance in so I
appreciate that as a family and I
appreciate the dope you know intro t
show me it was great big fan of this guy
you know what I'm saying an egg
congratulations on the PT site work on
and on top of that I swear to God I
turned the BT awards on twice and each
time it was it was that it was the big
boy performance in the sniper and
besides Royce I'll say Roy see yellow
wolf the hottest status vs on the cyclic
every birthday yeah it was a hotter than
you know me Wiz Khalifa balls raekwon
raekwon yeah right for sure man hello
that man
got out there before live with big boy
for the you ain't no DJ record yes shout
out the big boy for me down and a small
a man how did that happen cuz i know you
know you're from alabama Outkast is like
the pentacle I mean your lyrical dude so
I know you appreciate you know outcasts
how did how did that happen you know and
I'm saying the big boy reach out to you
team team ghetto vision kuwan Prater
over here who you know ghetto vision who
you know was part of the hawkeyes
movement you know ti of course unsure
John Legend and brother bear who was
helping to run purple ribbon with big
boy for a while who was my manager made
the connections you don't attend and it
took a while we had to get on her own
drugs that make a name for ourselves
definitely before big open up the door
and what I mean you know when you when
you want to work with someone of that
caliber you know you gotta gotta get
your game we just can't walk in there
most definitely that's that's a legend
right yeah so when I finally did it man
I just went for it though and I do gotta
say you wrapped alongside like when it
comes to southern hip hop one be big boy
and not to take anything away from
gambling
I mean to me outshine both of whom like
Oh lyrically I'm just saying like not to
take nothing away from bunt or big boy
but yo gonna really held your own like
love it I there's no way at all it's
impossible to outshine big boy or barbie
just a silly but like I said you held
your own man like like and that's got to
be was it when working with big boy and
bumpy in all these cats like what is
like the biggest challenge when writing
that verse that 16 that you know like
all right this is where this is for big
boys no I mean you just you know that
they've been so consistent for so many
years you know that they're gonna mark
it I so it's just like how do you go go
go all out how do you how do you stand
up next to it well it's just like really
just doing me man you know I just go in
there do the best that I possibly can do
most afternoons so that I make sure that
when people hear the collaboration that
I can shine you know next to our already
shining light listen legislate she's
jumping on there and ripping it now when
I you've quarter on trunk Muzik let's
kind of got your buzz heavy because you
know as far as mixed ages probably my
favorite mixtape this come
the album is it an album to trunk Muzik
0 to 60 is it an album or is it kind of
because I from what I understood is it
is that a lot of the material that's
already on trunk Muzik it's only well
you know when we saw him when we
designed with Interscope they wanted to
pick up Trump music and put it out we
decided together that we didn't want to
distribute a project that had been free
for a four years so what we did is we
took five of the fan favorites off a
truant music and put seven new records
on the other universe and so 0 to 60 is
just a rep you know just some metaphor
for you know get people up to speed the
most where I'm at you know it's
definitely as far as seven new songs I
mean of course you got you got gucci
mane on a new single anybody else that
you're working with on on any of the new
material that's going to be on the 0 to
60 oh yeah the I just wanna party a
record is going to be on 0 to 60 daddy's
Lambo will be on 026 drama beats
therefore drama beats yeah and all also
production from Jim Johnson on a record
called billy crystal meth a
collaboration production between Malay
and will pop from super hot beats for
record car get the [__] up yeah and
there's you know the rest is just in the
house man you know we kept it with the
crew right now you had you had to deal
before before Interscope a while ago
right before it before you kind of have
this resurgence yeah trunk Muzik um
what's the difference between the
situation we had in that and now that
you're with interesting you know it's a
totally totally different situation when
I signed with Columbia with KP ghetto
version Colombian 07 we didn't have any
kind of buzzed right you know and we
were really looking to use the major
label system to create a buzz as you
know now it's completely the internet
yet we left online and ghetto vision
television for the past couple years you
know we did our own you know period we
did everything by herself with like four
people
no we made it to South by Southwest for
the big you know performance festival
and we had already put out Trump music
in the video with pop the trunk yes your
parents in that video right here was my
folks in Gaston's my hometown those are
my friends yeah and I'm shot by motion
family they also shot by killing the
videos yeah they've been killing the
videos and a beast and I think they did
a trap going ham video Phil video yeah
yeah now they kill it and we just put in
a ton of work by ourselves so that when
we went to Interscope they understood
that we had put in a lot of work you
know and we had created this vehicle and
you know we just we needed a place to go
fuel up and they understood us
creatively you know and letting us do
what the [__] we want to do you know but
traditionally they're like that you know
you look at the acts they had before
they're all like that yeah most of you
know all left field you know so maybe
they just saw in the N word which is one
of my favorite new groups out of Africa
you know so yeah now when it comes to
tournament Wiz Khalifa man this tour is
I've been reading I mean you guys
selling out so many dates man what is a
I guess a story that you can share with
us man so far being on tour Wiz Khalifa
no such a such a popular tour man any
crazy like groupie stories or anything
you can share what is Eddie haha yeah
man I mean you know all the ladies
feeling I mean the oh man you got that
you got the you know the rock star ship
hopping off you know I'm saying yeah i
mean i love i love women you know so I
you know it's been a good luck so far
yes but so far what's your favorite city
so far honestly I have to say Vancouver
Vancouver yeah that's what he did eight
and I was exciting that's what's up now
I know you were a big beer drinker man
is a PBR all day or man you know I I
stay on some TBR's but um you know I
really have been on some Jack Daniels
lately for real Jack dance isn't Jack
Daniel going tough hard in the paint
that guy is straight straight damn i'm a
lightweight man I focal to Fat Tuesday
drinks you already know something hey
but I was going to ask you man um 0 to
60 records coming out you already have
like the official you know launch album
like your official first album because
like you said and you know 55 the
records you have already been out right
exactly yeah yeah already in the work
yes 0 to 60 is the warm up you know it's
warm up album that it'll be followed by
March release and that the name of that
yeah radioactive for anywhere yeah
radioactive is the more March release so
yeah man so we you know just going to
get out here grindin create more
awareness with zero to 60 and get people
ready for that much release what it is
man hey I appreciate the time I was a
brother appreciating me Yelawolf very
nose on ice and block